Marco Antonio is trying to attract
customers and get into the festive
Spirit he hopes to sell his robots with
some divine intervention
sales are very low they've gone down but
with God's blessing everything is
possible
[Music]
Chamber of Commerce says Christmas sales
are down 33 percent it's a blow to the
economy in the biggest shopping season
of the year
many people blame the wave of protests
that spread across Peru after the
impeachment and the rest of former
president Pedro Castillo
a day before Christmas Day and Fuentes
says she hasn't sold any of her knitwear
designs
sales have been very low in the past few
weeks because of the coup prices have
gone up the economy is very bad and so
are sales
political and social turmoil have
dampened festivities
Highway blockades cost transport costs
to increase and many stores closed
during the unrest
there has been a lot of uncertainty and
fear people don't go out to shop we had
to close the doors because of people who
wanted to loot foreign
as a result he says sales are 40 percent
lower than they were last year analysts
say the feeling of instability refrains
consumers from buying too many products
people prefer to buy food and keep their
savings untouched
the covid-19 pandemic left nearly 4
million people without a job the
association of small businesses says
former president Pedro Castillo didn't
Implement any support measures and now
they've lost more than half a billion
dollars in Christmas sales
business owners are calling for Urgent
assistance they want president Ina
boulevarde to focus on a contingency
plan to counter their losses for now
most of the protests have quietened down
for the deeply religious country it is a
break and an opportunity to celebrate
Mariana Sanchez